hello i am vim girl and i love talking
about tech in this video i'll be showing
you how to use redux
redux is a javascript library that helps
us manage our applications data and i'm
going to build this to do app using
redux to show you how it works
let's get started with the html code
i'll need an input box
a submit button and a div tag to display
the to do's
since we're using the redux library we
also need to add a script tag for redux
alright let's check it out
cool
now we're ready to write some redux
first thing we need to do is create a
reducer
to create a reducer we use redux dot
combine reducers which takes in an
object of functions
these functions run whenever dispatch is
called and the return value becomes our
app's new state you'll see what i mean
in a minute to start i'm just going to
return an array of deuce
groceries
make dinner
we use this reducer to create a store to
create a store we are going to use redux
dot create store and pass in my reducer
we'll be using this store for everything
like accessing the state and dispatching
events before we move on let's see how
we can access the state with the store
window.stores you go to store and we're
going to go to the chrome's console so
we can access the state by using stores
getstate function
cool
now we can see that my state currently
has what i put in earlier
okay
now that i've set up redux i need a
function called vendor that creates html
based on our state
let's get our container div and make
sure that it's empty
then we'll need to access the state of
our app and we can do that using
getstate
now i'm going to loop through each
element in my state and create a div
element for each item
i'll also need to display the errand
and append the new element to our
container div
now when we call the render function we
should be able to see our hard-coded
to-do list
awesome
okay next let's add functionality to the
page
we need to update the state when the
submit button is clicked so let's get
that button
to update our state we call the dispatch
function and pass in an object
we are required to pass in a type key i
usually name the value based on the
user's action so i'll call it add
i'm going to pass in another key called
item and its value will be whatever is
in the input box
after the dispatch function is called
our reducer will execute and we'll get
our new stake but first we'll need to go
back to our reducer real quick and make
sure that our state is updated
accordingly
alright we want to build on top of our
current state so we'll need to include
the state and action as parameters
when you start the app the initial state
will be an empty array
and action is the object we passed into
our dispatch function
it's best practice not to change the
default state so i'm going to use
object.assign to make a new copy of the
state
if action.type is add i'm going to add
the item into our new states array
then we're going to return the new state
okay let's go back to our onclick
function
after dispatching we should call the
render function to update our html based
on the new state
great now let's see what we have so far
cool now we can add to do's
let's add another functionality how
about when i click on an item
the item should be removed
so let's add another dispatch event for
each to-do element and give it a type
called remove we also need to pass in
the index and then render to refresh the
ui
let's make sure that for each is
providing that index
when the reducer function executes if
the type is removed i want to get rid of
that item
okay let's see if it works
awesome we're done
now let's recap what we need to have a
redux app running first we create a
reducer
then we use this reducer to create a
store
using this door we can call getstate to
get the state of our data
when user clicks on the submit button or
when they click on an item we use the
store to dispatch an event to change our
state
alright that's it for today if you have
any questions feel free to comment below